sehr geehrte damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zur pressekonferenz der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hier in
lindau wir haben einige ansprechpartner
für sie in den nächsten minuten
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn die
ministerin für arbeit und soziales und
integration des landes sachsen-anhalt
frau petra grimm benne die ministerin
für soziales gesundheit frauen und
familie des saarlands frau monika
bachmann und herrn professor dr original
sekretär der deutschen gesellschaft für
internistische intensivmedizin und
notfallmedizin und als gastgeber den
vorsitzenden der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz und
staatsminister für gesundheit und pflege
des freistaats bayern herrn klaus
holetschek wir werden erst einige
statements hören und sind dann offen für
ihre fragen herr minister jack bitte
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
herr bundesminister liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen professor jahns wir hatten
eine gesundheitsministerin
ministerkonferenz unter schwierigen
vorzeichen
die lage ist teilweise dramatisch
besorgniserregend und alles andere als
entspannend
bauen sind dieser konferenz allen
bewusst und wir haben ein großer
einigkeit dies auch noch mal in einer
erklärung festgehalten
dass die lage in deutschland
und zumindest in vielen regionen sehr
ernst ist und auch zunehmend ernster
wird vor diesem hintergrund gab es
einige beschlüsse die wir auch in großer
einigkeit gefasst haben und wo wir uns
auch in großer einigkeit klar sind dass
es wichtig ist diese dynamik die jetzt
da ist zu brechen da werden die
kolleginnen und kollegen dann im
einzelnen zu verschiedenen themen auch
noch stellung nehmen wichtig ist die
botschaft dass auffrischungsimpfungen
vom grundsatz nach sechs monaten für
alle möglich sein sollen insbesondere
natürlich für die gruppen medizinisches
personal ältere menschen aber wir wollen
damit und mit den erfahrungen aus israel
tatsächlich ganz stark in diese welle
reingehen und wollen alles tun gemeinsam
mit den ärztinnen und ärzten in diesem
land aber auch mit den impfzentren die
wir im standby modus gehalten haben
diese welle zu brechen und entschlossen
und ganz geschlossen hier gemeinsam
vorzugehen klar ist auch dass sich auf
den intensivstationen und das war jetzt
sehr eindrucksvoller professor lenzen
und auch die pflegekraft die mit dabei
war dass sich auf den intensivstationen
im moment eine ganz ganz schwierige
situation abspielt wir hatten wirklich
in dieser beschreibung dieser situation
von der pflegekraft alle noch mal
gemerkt unter welcher belastung die
pflegekräfte im moment stehen wie groß
der wille ist zu helfen und sich um die
patientinnen und patienten zu kümmern
und wie schwierig es ist weil
pflegekräfte
ihren beruf bereits verlassen haben weil
wir krankheitsfälle haben und auf den
intensivstationen vorwiegend natürlich
auch menschen die ungeimpft sind und das
ist glaube ich auch eine zentrale
botschaft die wir gemeinsam mit nehmen
wir haben auch ein papier verabschiedet
die ersten lehren aus dieser pandemie
und da ist es uns wichtig dass wir die
krankenhäuser in den fokus nehmen aber
auch das thema pflege wir müssen
unmittelbar ein signal setzen sei es
zulagen für die die kogit patienten
behandeln oder steuerliche anreize dass
wir dort die ersten signale reingeben
wie wichtig uns das ist und wir werden
uns auch insgesamt mit dieser situation
noch einmal auseinandersetzen müssen
pflege ist das megathema aus meiner
sicht für die nächsten politischen
bewertungen und in jeder ebene sei es
der bundes die länder oder auch die
kommunen wir wollen hier alles tun damit
wir nicht nur darüber reden sondern
damit wir tatsächlich auch die situation
deutlich verbessern wir wissen auch dass
wir im altenheim bereich und im
pflegebereich noch einmal gemeinsam ein
zeichen setzen wollen die sicherheit
dort hat für uns alle einen vorrang und
ist uns ganz zentral wichtig und von
großer bedeutung auch aus der erfahrung
der ersten wellen deswegen das thema
auffrischungsimpfungen gerade auch in
diesen wichtigen bereich aber auch noch
mal die signale des testens zb auch wenn
jemand geimpft und genießen ist noch mal
eine sicherheitsschleuse mit einem test
zu hinterlegen da wird der bund die
voraussetzungen auch schaffen dass dies
möglich ist und dass auch besucher dann
eben nicht gehindert werden wollen wir
dass diese tests auch in diesem bereich
kostenfrei zur verfügung gestellt werden
für besucherinnen und besucher in den
alten und pflegeheim so weit die ersten
eindrücke ich darf mich bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen wirklich
herzlich bedanken wir waren das erste
mal seit längerer zeit wieder in präsenz
zusammen das war auch wichtig wir haben
fast jede woche gemeinsam mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister in einer video
schalte verbracht und uns ausgetauscht
es war aber auch wichtig dass wir heute
noch einmal diese erfahrungen auch noch
mal miteinander geteilt haben und
gesehen haben wie ist die situation in
den ländern was können wir gemeinsam tun
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen wir blicken
mit großer sorge auf diese situation wir
haben das impfen wenn es so wäre dass
wir da noch viel mehr bewegung jetzt
rein bringen können auch in die die sich
zum ersten mal impfen lassen dann wäre
das wirklich gut und wichtig gerade in
dieser dramatisch besorgniserregenden
situation aus meiner sicht sind wir
mitten in einer notlage noch drin wir
brauchen sichere rechtsgrundlage für die
zukunft um handeln zu können ist auch
noch eine ganz zentrale botschaft und
wir müssen gemeinsam jetzt die nächsten
wochen und monate schauen dass wir die
belastung des gesundheitssystems wieder
auf ein normales maß zurück bringen das
gelingt aber nur wenn wir auch die zahl
der neuinfektionen wieder unterbrechen
und zurückbringen können vielen dank
herzlichen dank an minister herrmann ist
das sparen bitte ja meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren diese
gesundheitsministerkonferenz in präsenz
in lindau ist ja schon tatsächlich seit
längerem geplant auch als ein
regelmäßiger austausch
sie ist gleichwohl in dieser zeit jetzt
in der aktuellen lage auch ein wichtiges
signal der zusammenarbeit des
gemeinsamen handelns von bund und
ländern in dieser pandemie wir sind
gar nicht erst in der vierten welle die
vierte welle ist schon länger das sagen
wir auch schon länger wir merken aber
jetzt dass diese vierte welle mit voller
wucht
kommt dass sie deutlich an fahrt
aufgenommen hat mit rekord
infektionszahlen für deutschland in den
letzten 18 monaten mit einer sehr
starken zumindest regional auch
belastung von krankenhäusern sowohl im
normalstation bereich wie vor allem auch
auf den intensivstationen wir haben die
ersten regionen in deutschland in denen
auch patienten mit 19 patienten verlegt
werden müssen von einem standort zu
anderen standorten weil eben die
intensivstation voll sind dort in den
jeweiligen krankenhäusern und das macht
denke ich sehr eindrucksvoll deutlich
worum es gerade geht vor uns liegen sehr
schwere wochen das zeichnet sich allein
schon durch die hohen infektionszahlen
ab wir sehen im moment dass etwa
0,8 prozent knapp ein prozent der
infizierten der neuinfizierten dann
aller regel nach 10 14 tagen auf den
intensivstationen
behandlungsbedürftig werden heißt also
wenn wir heute knapp 40.000 neue
infizierte haben dann werden in einigen
tagen von ihnen 350 bis 400 dann neu
aufgenommen werden auf den
intensivstationen und das zeigt eben
dass das noch einige wochen sind so oder
so die sehr sehr schwierig werden umso
wichtiger ist es jetzt diese welle zu
brechen und einen entscheidenden
unterschied zu machen und ich bin sehr
dankbar darüber dass es gelungen ist bei
drei punkten drei wichtigen punkten
miteinander auch eine einigkeit zu
erzielen
zum ersten das 3g geimpft genesen oder
getestet als zugangsvoraussetzung vor
allem auch für veranstaltungen im
innenraum noch wichtiger geworden ist
vor allem auch die kontrolle wichtig ist
auch darüber besteht konsens dass wir
mehr kontrolle brauchen von 3g im alltag
damit es tatsächlich einen unterschied
machen kann dass es irgendwie nur
aufgeschrieben steht machen noch nicht
den unterschied es muss auch
kontrolliert und umgesetzt werden und
dazu kommt eben zweig geimpft oder
chinesen als option für regionen mit
einem sehr hohen infektionsgeschehen und
einer belastung auf den
intensivstationen die ersten länder
haben ja auch entsprechende zweig
regelungen schon eingeführt auch da ist
es zum ersten mal auch konsens zwischen
bund und allen ländern dass es solche
zweig regelungen in bestimmten regionen
eben auch geben muss das ist der erste
punkt der zweite wichtige punkt ist die
orte zu schützen wo die besonders
verwundbaren leben das sind die
pflegeeinrichtungen wir haben im letzten
winter erlebt wie brutal dieses virus in
den pflegeeinrichtungen gewütet hat wie
viele menschen an diese pandemie
eben haben lassen müssen gerade von den
höchst betagten und pflegebedürftigen
menschen das waren zu viele todesfälle
zu beklagen
und wir haben die instrumente in der
hand um das für diesen winter zu
vermeiden das eine sind die
auffrischimpfung auch dort sind alle
länder mit tempo schon seit wochen dabei
die ersten länder haben auch alle
pflegeeinrichtungen schon erreicht mit
auffrischimpfungen die angeboten worden
sind um den schutz zu erhöhen aber vor
allem auch mit verpflichtenden test
konzepten bei denen auch geimpfte und
genesene besucherinnen und besucher und
pflegekräfte regelmäßig getestet werden
müssen das ist ein ort wo besonders
verwundbare leben und deswegen braucht
es dort dem auch besondere besonders
hohe schutzmaßnahmen und das heißt dann
in einem solchen bereich auch geimpfte
und genesene die von außen in die
einrichtung kommen entsprechend zu
testen um zu schützen und der dritte
wichtige punkt der eine große rolle
gespielt hat sind die auffrischimpfungen
die booster impfung
wichtiges signal dieser tage dass sowohl
die ärzteschaft wie auch bund und länder
sich einig sind dass jeder bei dem die
zweitimpfung sechs monate oder länger
zurück liegt auch eine entsprechende
auffrischimpfung bekommen können soll
insbesondere empfohlen auch und auch
aktiv angeboten für die älteren für
ältere menschen für menschen mit
vorerkrankungen für medizinisches und
pflegerisches personal
und wir brauchen mehr tempo mehr
geschwindigkeit bei diesen
auffrischimpfungen das zeigen eben vor
allem auch die jüngsten erkenntnisse
also das ist so einen unterschied macht
einen so klaren auch um eine welle zu
brechen ist ja eine erkenntnis die wir
erst seit wenigen tagen wochen haben das
sollten wir aber jetzt auch nutzen diese
erkenntnis in dem wir eben mehr tempo
bei den auffrischimpfungen machen muss
dann nach sechs monaten sollte die regel
werden nicht die ausnahme und das gilt
wie gesagt insbesondere für ältere für
menschen mit vorerkrankungen für
medizinisches und pflegerisches personal
ich bin dankbar dass wir uns einig sind
dass die praxen die arztpraxen die
niedergelassene bereich aber natürlich
eine wichtige rolle hat aber ist eben
auch angebote der öffentlichen hand
braucht impfstellen im bus
oder impfzentren wo eben angesichts der
großen zahl wir können das ja rechnen
wer vor sechs monaten geimpft wurde die
zahl wächst jetzt immer weiter hoch weil
wir ja april mai juni auch immer mehr
geschwindigkeit bei den ersten zwei
impfungen haben entwickeln können und
dann brauchen wir zusätzlich zu den
arztpraxen eben auch die öffentlichen
angebote und ich bin dankbar dass das
konsens ist abschließend möchte ich nur
eins sagen weil der check das auch
angesprochen hat das war sehr
eindrucksvoll der professor janssens als
intensivmediziner aber eben auch
die pflegekräfte mit denen wir
diskutiert haben das einfach
eindrucksvoll einmal mehr aus dem alltag
von der intensivstation die lage
geschildert zu bekommen und man merkt
die pflegekräfte brennen für ihre arbeit
fehler sind mittlerweile auch
ausgebrannt sie sind müde so viel frust
da weil durch impfungen viel von der
belastung die sie im alltag erleben im
moment mit kurven 19 patienten auch
hätte vermieden werden können
ich kann einfach nur dafür werben jeder
der krone leugnet er sagt dieses virus
ist nicht so schlimm
jeder der zögert überlegt
ob er sich impfen lassen soll oder nicht
jeder der glaubt er ist jung gesund und
verwundbar
sollte vielleicht einfach mal mit
pflegekräften vor allem intensiv
pflegekräften und medizinern sprechen
und sich ein bild machen auch von dem
was auf den intensivstationen zumindest
in vielen regionen in deutschland gerade
wieder los ist und dann sieht man eben
schon sehr klar worum es geht in dieser
pandemie es geht darum dass wir uns
gegenseitig schützen dass wir auch
weiterhin gut aufeinander aufpassen es
ist deutlich vielmehr alltag möglich
überlegen sie mal die inzidenz die wir
jetzt haben ohne impfstoffe und
impfungen
jeder erinnerten auch die maßnahmen aus
den letzten herbst und winter die wollen
wir vermeiden wir können mit den
impfungen entscheidenden unterschied
machen aber dafür ist es jetzt eben
wichtig diese welle zu brechen gut
aufeinander aufzupassen also ein alltag
ja mehr alltag aber mit vorsicht mit
vorsichtsmaßnahmen aha regeln
schutzmaske in bus und bahn im
einzelhandel im öffentlichen raum und
vor allem mit vielen auffrischimpfungen
über das gemeinsam machen gelingt es
eben auch diese welle zu brechen und
einen entscheidenden unterschied zu
machen ist liegt am ende an jedem
einzelnen von uns jeden tag
herzlich danke minister und als nächstes
bitte frau ministerin grimm benne
herzlichen dank meine damen und herren
ich bin ministerin für arbeit soziales
gesundheit und gleichstellung und
vertrete hier heute die a seite aber das
möchte ich gar nicht so betonen sondern
die b seite steht sozusagen mit der
kollegin bachmann neben mir und ich bin
ganz dankbar dass wir heute alles
einheitliche beschlüsse gefasst haben
weil wir auch deutlich machen wollen
dass es hier keine politische
gesundheitsministerkonferenz gewesen wo
wir unterschiedliche auffassungen
vertreten haben sondern sie war von den
geprägt was ja hier schon anschaulich
sowohl der bundesminister als auch der
vorsitzende gesagt haben ich möchte
ihnen einen besonderen mir wichtigen
beschluss näher bringen das sind das was
auch heute professorin sind seinen
vortrag auch gesagt hat alle
krankenhäuser wissen darum dass es
wahrscheinlich wieder darum geht um die
intensivmedizinische versorgung
sicherzustellen
bestimmte elektiven eingriffe wieder zu
verschieben und das macht es
erforderlich dass wir auch diese
maßnahmen gezielt finanziell ausgleichen
deswegen haben wir
uns einstimmig ja ich will nicht sagen
in die hand versprochen aber wir haben
gesagt das braucht es unbedingt dass er
wieder ausgleichs und aufschlags zahlung
machen allerdings für diejenigen die
tatsächlich stationäre patienten cupid
19 patientinnen und patienten aufnehmen
wie wollen wir unterstützen und das
wollen wir schon rückwirkend zum 1
november 20 21 schaffen dafür brauchen
wir bestimmte maßnahmen die das wieder
verlängern und wir haben auch gesagt
sonstige entlastende maßnahmen müssen
wir wieder reaktivieren damit
tatsächlich die krankenhäuser auch
wieder bereit sind aufzunehmen und ihren
schweren dienst auch dort tun können und
dass sie die sorge haben dort
wirtschaftliche probleme zu bekommen es
wird von uns einen kraftakt sowieso
schon sein es ist ausgeführt worden wir
haben
personalengpässe gerade bei den
intensivstationen und wir müssen alles
daran tun was ist ja hier schon zum
ausdruck gekommen worden dass wir die
pflegekräfte unterstützen und dass wir
alles tun und da nehme ich mich genau so
dass wir erst mal alles verhindern
müssen dass wir so viele kuwait
patienten patienten in den
krankenhäusern aufnehmen müssen deswegen
unterstützen wir das auch in sich der
booster impfungen und ein weiterer
beschluss ist ja noch mal zu dem
weiteren testen und testmöglichkeiten je
nach akademischer lage in den
altenpflegeheimen wir wollen noch mal
auch in den herbst und winter hinein
nicht diejenigen wieder auch isolieren
sondern wir wollen gucken dass wir über
ein festes test regime unter wirklich
auch vielen kontrollen es ermöglichen
können dass wir nicht so eine situation
erleben wir im letzten weihnachten
sondern dass wir auch wieder besuch
unter angehörigen dass wir sozusagen die
altenpflegeeinrichtung auch offen halten
ich glaube es ist auch für die ältere
bevölkerung ganz wichtig dass wir dieses
signal hier auch nochmal aber wir müssen
sicher sein dass sie oft anderen seite
auch schützen und deswegen auch noch
mein appell es ist ja schon viel über
mögliche im pflichten gesprochen werden
ich mag mir das immer noch nicht in
dieser konsequenz vollständig habe in
unserem land jetzt erstmal eine abfrage
macht den altenpflegeheimen wie
tatsächlich der impfstatus ist um dann
noch mal zu gucken ob man nicht doch
noch mal sagen kann es gibt eine
moralische verpflichtung sich impfen zu
lassen damit man diejenigen die man
pflegt auch schützt so weit erst mal von
mir
erzählen frau ministerin und frau
ministerin bachmann bitte ja meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren minister
sparen hat eben gesagt wir haben harte
wochen vor uns wir haben aber auch zwei
harte jahre schon hinter uns und deshalb
war das dank des vorsitzlandes bayern
eine ganze arbeitsintensive
gesundheitsministerkonferenz die wir in
den zwei tagen jetzt absolviert haben
ich war heute morgen sehr dankbar dafür
dass
der kollege holt check dem professor
jantzen eingeladen hatte mit einem gegen
sluiter und vor allen dingen einer
examinierten
intensivpflege kraft die uns deutlich
gemacht hat wie es aussieht ganz zwar
gewusst aber wir haben es nie so
deutlich vielleicht gehört wie heute
morgen in dem die pflegekräfte am ende
sind sie sind ein vermögen die sind
kaputt die können dann mit fünf tage
frei machen sie werden zurückgerufen
weil zu wenige da sind dafür herr
professor jansen ein herzliches
dankeschön dass es so ist wie sie gesagt
haben wir mediziner wir fliege treffen
lassen niemanden im stich wir sind da
wenn wir gebraucht werden aber wir waren
nicht alleine mit unseren ministerien
sondern wir haben noch einen punkt den
ich an schneiden will und zwar den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
ohne den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
werden wenn ich in der situation wie wir
heute sind auch mit der kontakt nach
verfolgung dass wir dort wirklich mit
unseren gesundheitsämtern vor ort auch
dies geleistet haben mit einem sehr
großen aufwand und deshalb sieht der
pakt mit dem gd welcher im september 220
geschlossen wurde neben den mitteln der
personalisierung sowie der steigerung
der attraktivität und
etablierung zukunftsfähiger strukturen
zusätzlich mittel von 800 millionen euro
für das vorantreiben der technischen und
prozessualen modernisierung des led und
das ist notwendig das ist notwendig
damit wir vor ort auch handlungsfähig
sind damit unsere person ämter so
arbeiten können ich weiß von was ich
rede ich war lange zeit landräte also
auch leiterin und verantwortlich für
meinen gesundheitsamt und deshalb herr
bundesminister sparen bin ich dankbar
weil es ihr thema genau war in dem sie
deutlich gemacht habe wie schaffen es
nur gemeinsam mit der ärzteschaft mit
der pflegschaft mit den zuständigen
ministerien mit den landesregierungen
aber auch mit der dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und auch dort will ich
erwähnen dass wir eine große hilfe
hatten wir hatten eine große hilfe weil
wir das einfach nicht mehr geschafft
haben wie kontakt nachverfolgung die für
uns gar an
da ist die bundeswehr eingesprungen wir
haben hilfe erbeten und wir haben dort
auch hilfe erhalten aus diesem grund
glaube ich dass diese mittel die ich
eben angesprochen haben sollen über
finanzhilfen nach artikel 104b absatz 1
des grundgesetzes und über ein
förderprogramm an die länder ausgegeben
werden alles in allem hat die
kolleginnen das schon angesprochen indem
wir deutlich machen dass wir angefangen
haben zu kämpfen in unseren ländern in
den alten einrichtungen wir sind dann in
den alten einrichtungen zu der
eingliederungshilfe zu den werkstätten
für menschen mit behinderungen wir haben
eine zweitimpfung gemacht und sind jetzt
dabei die booster impfung zu machen und
das ist richtig so weil es die leute
nicht mehr weg sterben dürfen und das
ist auch in meinem bundesland gott sei
dank so und in vielen anderen auch aber
wir haben auch eine unterschiedliche
lage in den einzelnen bundesländer und
da glaube ich lieber kollege glas
politik dass wir gute beschlüsse gefasst
haben die genau die situation
widerspiegeln in unseren eigenen
bundesländer dafür sind wir da hat dafür
sind der
gesundheitsminister dafür haben wir
unsere ministerien und alle die mit uns
helfen und diese aufgabe wollen wir auch
gerecht werden ich danke ihnen für das
interesse
herzlichen dank frau ministerin und herr
professor dr janssens bitte ja sehr
geehrter herr minister erst mal möchte
mich dafür bedanken dass wir eingeladen
worden sind ich finde es besonders dass
die pflegekraft aus münchen dabei
gewesen ist weil ich erlebt dass
tagtäglich und ich erlebe viele solcher
berichte aber das war noch mal sehr
eindringlich und das hat uns allen noch
mal vor augen führt wo wir uns befinden
genau heute vor drei wochen habe ich
eine krankenschwester eine leitende
pflegekraft einer station die 45 jahren
den gleichen kamm ausgearbeitet in ihrem
ruhestand verabschiedet eine
fantastische pflegekraft und die hat
jetzt 19 monate lang nicht die
intensivstationen bedient sondern die
kurve 19 station wo nicht defensiv
richtige patienten liegen und sie hat
wirklich gesagt es waren die schlimmsten
19 monate ihres gesamten berufslebens
und sie ist dankbar dass sie jetzt in
vorstand gehen dürfte hätte das auch
nicht länger mehr geschafft und das hat
mir auch noch mal so gezeigt wo wir
stehen das war genau so ein bild und das
war eine hoch engagiert und ist eine
engagierte pflegekraft und das erleben
wir und wir haben 2009 10 schon
befragung durchgeführt und da haben uns
pflegekräfte auf intensivstationen schon
das signal gegeben dass sie schon vor
der korona pandemie dass ich unter
erheblichen belastung leiden und 30
prozent haben gesagt wir denken darüber
nach in den nächsten fünf jahren den
beruf oder zumindest das arbeitsumfeld
zu verlassen genau das haben wir jetzt
die situation dass deutsche bank das
institut hat uns diese woche daten
gezeigt wo genau in der abfrage dass in
den krankenhäuser stattfindet und ich
glaube meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das ist das problem was wir jetzt
im moment haben im moment haben wir gott
sei dank und das dank der impfungen noch
nicht so viele kurven 19 patienten auf
den stationen
das ist ergebnis der impfung dafür sind
wir dankbar aber wir haben volle
intensivstationen und eines dürfen wir
nicht vergessen wir haben eine kuh mit
19 situation aber wir haben viel viel
mehr patienten ohne cockpit 19 diese
patientinnen und patienten notfall
erkrankte müssen wir mit der gleichen
qualität und der gleichen sorgfalt und
mit der gleichen intensität
stationär ambulant und auf den
intensivstationen versorgen und da
geraten wir jetzt angesichts des
personalmangels der wirklich evident da
ist in die quadratur des kreises und
geraten tatsächlich und das ist auch die
derzeitige stimmung dass es keinen
alarmismus was ich immer höre sondern es
ist einfach nur eine warnung dass wir
eine kritische grenze an gestoßen sind
ich sage ihnen eines meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir werden
das schaffen und es ist völlig klar dass
die intensiv pflegekräfte die
pflegekräfte ambulant stationär die
aufgaben der letzten nächsten monate
schultern werden aber die blessuren die
jetzt schon da sind die werden stärker
werden und wir haben schon große sorge
was kommt danach und die konzepte die
heute beschlossen worden sind von der
gmk sind sinnvoll sind wichtig und im
zentrum stehen tatsächlich die impfungen
im zentrum stehen auch die testungen es
ist gut dass wir hier weiter kommen und
wir müssen das wissen wir sehr genau mit
dem booster impfung jetzt haben wir im
gegensatz zum letzten jahr eine waffe in
der hand wo wir das virus zumindestens
perspektivisch eindämmen können rücken
können wir werden meine damen und herren
mit dem virus weiter leben und sie wären
instrument in den nächsten jahren finden
wie wir mit dem leben und dann wird die
impfungen eine der zentralen maßnahmen
spielen dass wir tatsächlich mit diesem
virus weiter leben arbeiten können und
uns damit ich fest von überzeugt frei
bewegen werden können das werden wir
schon schaffen die nächsten monate
werden hart da bin ich mir ganz sicher
und ich bin mir auch ganz sicher dass
wir das schaffen werden und wir sind
dankbar wenn wir jetzt die signale
bekommen von der gmk dass hier
tatsächlich die häuser die stationen die
intensivstation die wirklich sich um
diese menschen schwerpunktmäßig kümmern
dass die tatsächliche entlastung
erfahren dass die häuser finanzielle
kompensation bekommen wenn sie sich
stark engagieren in dem kampf gegen die
pandemie und in der sorge für die
patientinnen und patienten und last not
least und damit vielleicht dem
pflegepersonal so ein bisschen last von
der schulter nehmen und ihnen vielleicht
am ende des jahres noch ein bisschen
luft gegeben dass sie doch vielleicht
ein gutes fest zusammen haben werden ich
danke ihnen
herzlich dank meine damen und herren für
ihre statements wenn sie es jetzt fragen
gibt's nehmen wir sie gerne stellen sie
sich bitte ganz kurz vor und welches
medium sich hier sind hier vorne bitte
christoph linke und der stuttgarter
zeitung stuttgarter nachrichten
ich habe eine frage die die konkrete
niederschlags kraft ihrer beschlüsse
bezüglich waren jetzt zwei punkte zum
beispiel mehr kontrollen im alltag das
ist eigentlich sache der
ordnungsbehörden also von städten und
gemeinden
der zweite punkt mehr öffentliche
impfzentren wieder öffnen dass es sache
der länder also kurzum die frage haben
ihre beschlüsse jetzt in diesen beiden
produkten zum beispiel nicht mehr
appellativen charakter
es ist ja so dass wir auf länderebene
bestimmte maßnahmen vollziehen und sie
haben es ja richtig angesprochen das
thema kontrolle ist eine sache die
ausländer ebene umgesetzt wird aber es
ist ja wichtig dass wir uns insgesamt
einig sind dass wir dieses
kontrollsystem erhöhen dass das auch
eine klare botschaft ist an die menschen
in diesem land überall wo sie leben und
sind dass wir nicht bereit zuzuschauen
wenn dinge die notwendig sind um unser
gesundheitssystem zu schützen nicht
kontrolliert nicht vollzogen werden
natürlich wird jeder von uns mit seinem
innenminister mit den behörden sei es
die ordnungsämter das heißt die polizei
diese themen jetzt auch umsetzen das ist
ja die botschaft wir haben uns committed
und geeinigt und wir setzen diese dinge
jetzt im land um das thema der
impfzentren ist ein beschluss den wir
schon mal gefasst haben gott sei dank
haben wir gesagt wir wollen diese nicht
ganz abschaffen und wir waren uns heute
noch mal einig dass das thema der
ärztinnen und ärzte im vordergrund steht
natürlich auch die haben uns viel
geholfen aber dass wir jetzt auch die
bereitschaft noch man überall haben
gemeinsam diesen weg zu gehen insofern
müssen wir natürlich umsetzen habe ich
glaube die einheitlichkeit auf diesem
weg ist auch eine wichtige botschaft ins
land will es noch mal sagen die lage
auch wenn sie in den bundesländern
teilweise noch unterschiedlich ist ist
insgesamt dramatisch und
besorgniserregend dann braucht sich
keiner etwas vormachen und wir wollen
auch niemand mit irgendwelchen buildings
in falscher sicherheit wiegen wir sind
jetzt noch mal an einem punkt in dieser
pandemie der professor jahns beschrieben
der schwere wochen vor uns hat und da
wollen wir mit all dem was wir zur
verfügung haben gemeinsam auffahren
gehen
eine zweite frage dort hinten noch einen
tisch weiter erst
unser minister manfred bucher war jetzt
heute nicht mehr dabei aber er hat vor
der konferenz doch eine starke forderung
gestellt nämlich die dass man jetzt doch
mal drüber sprechen sollte
pflegekräfte aber auch lehrer und
erzieher
verpflichten zu impfen inwieweit war das
thema bei der konferenz und warum ist
das immer noch ein thema das man nicht
so richtig anfassen mag so weit
zumindest mein eindruck und eine zweite
frage wenn ich darf die impfzentren die
wieder reaktiviert werden sollen woher
soll da das personal kommen und wie
lange dauert das bis die tatsächlich
wieder aktiv sein können danke also zu
den impfzentren kann ich vielleicht was
sagen zur impfpflicht war natürlich ein
thema in den diskussionen kann gern der
bundesminister oder auch die kolleginnen
was sagen ich kann für bayern das system
noch einmal darstellen damit wir wissen
von was wir in bayern zb sprechen wir
haben 81 impfstellen oder impfzentren
die im standby modus sind wir haben
diese impfungen die zur verfügung
gestellt werden können damals reduziert
weil wir gesehen haben im impfzentrum
war kaum noch jemand da und wissen sie
in dieser pandemie ist schon auch so das
muss man an dieser stelle auch mal sagen
wenn du im zentrum betreibst und es
kommt niemand dann heißt es werden
steuergelder verschwendet gehört auch
zur wahrheit dazu wenn politik dann
entscheidet und handelt kommt sofort
natürlich irgendwo eine keule aus der
ecke auf der anderen seite haben wir
damals genau gewusst wenn wir die
vollkommen abschaffen und wir kommen
wieder in eine situation wie jetzt dann
wird man uns vorwerfen dass wir nicht
voraus gedacht hätten deswegen ist es
gut dass diese impfzentren da sind wir
haben 240 mobile teams in bayern und ich
kann ihnen nur sagen haben jetzt mit
roten kreuz mit hilfsorganisationen auch
mit landräten gesprochen das dauert
natürlich ein bisschen bis man die volle
kapazität hochfahren kann die glaube ich
brauchen wir aber nicht weil die ärztin
ärzte da ja im privat auch mit drin sind
aber wir können stufenweise relativ
zügig wieder hochfahren das haben wir
die hilfs das hat mir die
hilfsorganisationen auch bestätigt dass
müssen wir halt jetzt als signal
aussenden deswegen sind solche
konferenzen schon wichtig dass wir eine
geeinte kommunikation auch haben nach
draußen dorthin wo es ist und jedes land
wird jetzt selber auch im system schauen
wo brauche ich die kapazität wie fahre
ich sie wieder hoch und wie können wir
das gemeinsam machen
wirklich vielleicht nur ganz kurz
ergänzen denn das heißt er dann immer
erst hat er so geschlossen jetzt werden
sie wieder geöffnet das war eine
bewusste entscheidung
zum 30 09 als die eben begannen sehr
sehr leer zu werden weil bei den erst-
und zweitwohnungen wir jedenfalls in
allergrößten teil erreicht hatten und
dass die auffrischimpfung eine solch
entscheidende bedeutung bekommen können
er ist übrigens ein großes glück dass
das so ist soll jetzt haben wir wirklich
ein instrument in der hand um diesen
unterschied zu machen diese erkenntnisse
auch was die nachlassende vor allem auch
nicht infektiosität angeht und dass das
eben einen unterschied machen kann in
einer welle die erkenntnis aus israel
das hat sich in den letzten wochen immer
mehr verdichtet und das ist jetzt mit
sehr eindrucksvollen zahlen sehr klar
belegbar deswegen haben wir damals 28
juni weiß ich noch bnk in münchen
wenn an der vereinbart eben ist gegen
strukturen in den standby betrieb und
werden auch mitfinanziert vom bund wir
werden auch jetzt wieder stärker in die
finanzierung mit einsteigen für die
strukturen die aufgebaut werden damit
man eben schnell auch wieder starten
kann das müssen jetzt nicht nur die
großen zentralen impfzentren wieder sein
es geht auch darum manche länder haben
ist auch übrigens ein unterschied ob es
ein stadtstaat ist oder ein flächenstaat
natürlich manche länder haben im stellen
im busse mobile teams in ganz
unterschiedlichen dimensionen aber das
ist neben den arztpraxen eben verstärkt
und vermehrt auch wieder das angebot
sozusagen des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes gibt es öffentlichen
bereiches gibt darum geht es und da bin
ich sehr dankbar dass wir uns darauf
haben verständigen können und das jetzt
eben jedes land nach seiner struktur die
sache noch einmal ein unterschied ob sie
in der großstadt das machen oder im
ländlichen raum genau diese öffentlichen
angebote schafft zur verpflichtenden
impfung also ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass wir darüber nicht genug reden wurde
ja schon über die verpflichtende impfung
geredet bevor es den impfstoff gab die
diskussion ist da ist auch gut dass sie
geführt wird
aber es gibt in argumente dafür und
dagegen
es gibt argumente dafür einige sind
genannt worden aus meiner sicht gibt es
argumente dagegen das sage ich als
jemand der ja etwa bei der
verpflichtenden masernimpfungen die auch
eingeführt hat in deutschland aber wir
sind gerade in einer pandemie in einer
zeit seit 18 monaten mit vielen vielen
spannung der zeit wo jeder erlebt in der
familie
ist diskussion teilweise
es fängt schon bei der frage an tragen
die kinder in der schule maske oder
nicht da geht es auf einem elternabend
ziemlich spannungsreich zu wo die einen
sagen unbedingt und die anderen sagen
auf keinen fall und das ist bei den
impfungen noch mehr mit spannung jetzt
schon
was er erlebt während des wahlkampfes
auch bei über 100 veranstaltungen wobei
fast jeder veranstaltung rund um die
veranstaltung auch deutlich geworden ist
dass impfen
machen gott sei dank die allermeisten
die schützen sich einfach da sind noch
nicht die lauten aber es gibt immer auch
einige bei denen löst das eine ziemliche
gegenwehr aus und solange noch ein
gespräch miteinander möglich ist bleibt
eine gesellschaft zusammen solange wir
über die dinge reden können argumente
austauschen sagen können schaut auf die
intensivstation warum impfen sinnvolles
meine sorge ist wenn sie fragen warum
ich das nach abwägung anders sie ist die
dass eine in einer solchen
spannungsreichen zeit eine
verpflichtende impfung zu spaltungen
führen kann und wie möglicherweise dann
viele gar nicht mehr erreichen gar nicht
mehr zum gespräch kommen weil man gar
nicht mehr zuhört und im übrigen ist
meine sorge auch das würde ich auch so
aussprechen wir haben regionen ja da ist
etwa auch beim pflegepersonal leider die
impfquote nicht vor allem auch nicht nur
aber auch in der altenpflege nicht so
hoch wie man es nicht unbedingt wünschte
und wie es auch erwarte ich finde wer
mit verwundbaren alten menschen arbeitet
und sie pflegt hat eine moralische
pflicht sich zu impfen
wenn wir jetzt sagen würden impfpflicht
und 30 prozent sind auf einmal kommen
die ich habe die sorge mancher lässt
sich nicht impfen der kommt einfach
nicht mehr zur arbeit
der pflicht denn dann die alten menschen
deswegen ist ist wichtig damit für die
älteren schützen das ist die tests
pflichten ausgeweitet werden im übrigen
wissen wir eben auch trotz impfung kann
es sein dass man in eine
pflegeeinrichtung das virus einträgt und
deswegen ist die richtige antwort aus
meiner sicht eine deutliche ausweitung
jetzt für herbst und winter vor allem
der test verpflichtung wieder für die
pflegeeinrichtung und die pflegeheime
gegebenenfalls auch vier kliniken und
die verwundbaren zu schützen aber in der
abwägung nicht eine verpflichtende
impfung dem zweifel spaltungen auslöst
ich will noch meine deutlichkeit markt
zu den es wird ja so gesagt dass ob
würde ich jetzt alle wieder hochfahren
müssen oder nur im standby sind also wir
haben nur die großen zentren geschlossen
weil da es wurde war sozusagen der
aufwand auch der finanzielle aufwand zu
dem nutzen derjenigen die zum impfen
gekommen sind zu gering außerdem wurde
uns immer vorgeworfen dass es große
tanker sind welche die wo es schnell
gehen soll aber kein angebot ist
insbesondere für diejenigen die wir
jetzt die boost der impfungen tun wollen
da war immer die schlechte
erreichbarkeit zu weit weg und deswegen
haben wir die ganze zeit in landkreisen
und kreisfreien städte die möglichkeit
gegeben weiter mit mobilen
teams zu arbeiten und unterschiedliche
niederschwellige angebote zu machen also
wir konnten uns ja hier von dem impf bus
in lindau am 10 wir haben öfter mal vor
fußballspielen oder in einkaufszentren
mobil im dienst die ganze zeit
unterwegs ergänzt natürlich zu den
gesamten ärzten und ich kann sagen für
unser land wenn sie gucken wir sind ein
flächenland wir haben eine hohe
demografische entwicklung und wir haben
als es im sommer schon los geht es waren
ja die in den altenpflegeheimen die
ersten die geimpft haben und auch
zweimal geimpft haben auch da haben wir
jetzt schon die booster impfung begonnen
und gerade die menschen noch mal zu
schützen und in der bereich dann auch
nochmal denjenigen die sich bisher haben
noch nicht impfen lassen nämlich den
pflegekräften die möglichkeit zu geben
guckt es ist jetzt über ein jahr her es
ist im grunde nicht das passiert was ihr
vermutet habt
es gibt ja viele fake news gerade auch
bei mir im land die bestimmte sachen
gedacht haben was dann mit ihnen
passiert und nutzt es nochmal zu den
erst impfungen und wir werden das
ausbauen damit wird tatsächlich vor
diese welle kommen also für uns ist ganz
wichtig dass wir jetzt die die über
70-jährigen und dann die danach kommen
wir haben uns heute verständigt dass
jeder der will ne booster impfung
bekommen kann und
deswegen muss man gucken wir erwarten
dass wir im dezember januar eine größere
anzahl haben ein booster impfungen und
da haben wir auch noch ein bisschen zeit
diese entweder im teams oder eben auch
die krankenhäuser haben ja mittlerweile
auch die möglichkeiten zu impfen viele
orte gibt es die möglichkeit dass er
dann noch mal verschärft gucken dass wir
dann auch diese wirklich diese bälle
abfangen können
sie haben zwei kurzen fragen gestellt
ich will ihnen zwei kurze antworten
geben einmal die öffnung der impfzentren
ich werde es nicht tun wenn ich es tun
würde dauert es etwa 14 tage bis die aus
dem standby wieder nach oben gefahren
werden also wäre es möglich aber wir
haben im moment eine situation mit der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung dass die
kassen ärzte vereinigung zu uns nach der
ärzte wir schaffen das und das halt noch
die impfquote in meinem land wir haben
18 bei 90% und wir haben über unter 18
also wenn ich die mit rechner bei 74
prozent
das ist natürlich großartig und ich bin
dankbar dass die erste das somit mal die
zweite frage aber die im zentren sind
standby also wenn jetzt zum beispiel der
gesundheitsminister beschluss anklang
findet würde bei der siko dass die sie
kämpfen jetzt alles booster impfung ab
18 oder ab 60 dann haben wir natürlich
eine andere situation
jetzt können wir es genau beziffern er
ist sechs monate in pflanzen und wer ist
jetzt berechtigt zu der booster impfung
also der sabbat ist nun zweiter manfred
lukas
natürlich haben wir darüber diskutiert
ich lehne es ab etwas unter zwang zu
machen so lange es geht es kann morgen
anders sein ich sage auch deshalb weil
ich lieber überzeuge und die
überzeugungsarbeit ist anstrengend aber
sie lohnt sich auch bei der fan von
so ich habe jetzt noch fünf frage
meldung bei denen müssen uns belassen
und wenig aus dem rahmen laufend mit der
bitte um eine kurze frage erste frage
hier rückfrage zum thema eurich mendelin
schwäbischer zeitung rückfrage zum thema
testen in altenheimen sie haben gesagt
regelmäßig also jetzt beim personal
leisten regelmäßig heiße dass eine
tägliche testpflicht und wer ist aber
verständlich bund oder land
also regelmäßig heißt regelmäßig für
mich wäre idealerweise täglich eine
testung angezeigt in diesem bereich
insbesondere in regionen ich würde das
auch incidents ab ich machen wenn sie in
einer region sind mit geringem
infektionsgeschehen dann kann man
sicherlich auch mit zwei bis dreimal die
woche
arbeiten in einer region oben
infektionsgeschehen jedenfalls kann ich
nur eine tägliche testung dann empfehlen
die tests sind kostenlos werden vom bund
finanziert bei den pflegeeinrichtungen
auch bezahlt für die pflegeeinrichtung
übrigens nicht nur die sachkosten
sondern auch die personalkosten werden
heute miteinander vereinbart dass wir
erst möglich machen wollen dass mit
entsprechenden bestätigungen geimpft und
genesene personen die einen angehörigen
besuchen wollen zum beispiel in der
pflegeeinrichtung auch die test stellen
wieder nutzen können sollen kostenlos
das wird auch der bund an übernehmen
aber eben für diejenigen die
nachweislich einen angehörigen besuchen
wollen in einer pflegeeinrichtung das
ist ja wichtig wir wollen natürlich dass
der besuch möglich ist der kontakt
möglich ist aber er muss sie eben unter
besonderen schutzvorkehrungen möglich
sein ich weiß dass das eine zusätzliche
belastung ist auch für die angehörigen
aber es machen wir ja nicht um
irgendjemanden zu ärgern wir machen es
vor allem um die höchst betagten auch
daniel familienmitglieder zu schützen
zweite frage von
daniel knopp bayerische rundfunk herr
söder hatte ja gesagt es wäre gut wenn
jetzt jeder eine eine antikörper also
der jetzt bereits geimpft ist natürlich
wenn er eine antikörper bestimmung
machen würde
mediziner sagen doch aber das bringt
doch eigentlich gar nicht so viel ist
das jetzt sinnvoll sollte das jeder
machen
naja es gibt alles zu mir also ich kann
ihnen ganz klare antwort darauf geben
antikörper bestimmung sagen darüber was
aus habe ich kontakt gab mit dem virus
also hat mein körper irgendetwas gegen
den virus unternommen dann kann ich
nachweisen ich kann auch nachweisen die
spiegel der antikörper nach den
impfungen aber jetzt kommt die traurige
botschaft es sagt mir letztendlich nicht
wir wissen nicht ganz genau inwieweit
der gemessen an den spiegel in der lage
ist und zu sagen dieser mensch ist zu
100 50 60 70 prozent geschützt von da
muss ich ganz ehrlich würden die
antikörper spiegel bestimmung die es ja
gibt durchaus nicht dazu beitragen dass
wir eine vernünftige management in
dieser ganzen situation haben dass sie
wieder das jetzt formuliert hat aber es
gab jetzt gerade noch in jamaika sind
eine ganz klare und im yaam ein
wichtiges amerikaner steuern eine klare
stellungnahmen dazu dass hier an der
stelle die antikörper spiele
bestimmungen in
entscheidungen die jetzt epidemiologisch
getroffen werden müssten nicht so
hilfreich sind beiträgen wir schon mal
andersrum es geht jetzt vor allem auch
darum die auffrischimpfungen das
bewusstsein für wen macht das sinn und
wir sehen einfach das zeigen wirklich
die wissenschaftlichen daten sehr sehr
klar dass bei älteren bei menschen mit
vorerkrankungen
die monat vor teilweise sogar schon nach
der erste und zweite impfung von anfang
an etwas schwächer war als bei jüngeren
und die studienlage zeigt auch sehr klar
dass eine booster impfung gerade für
diesen personenkreis teilweise das
zwanzigfache eine 20 fache erhöhung des
impfschutzes durch diese dritte impfung
erreicht wird das hat unter anderem herr
professor sander vorgestern in berlin
auch noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht und
insofern gilt es eben ja gerade für
diese personengruppen die jetzt ja auch
nach der 6 monats logik das muss man ja
gelegentlich mal erinnern wenn wir jetzt
schauen wen haben wir vor sechs monaten
sieben monaten acht monaten zuerst
geimpft dann waren das ja vor allem auch
zuerst die älteren wir hatten ja eine
priorisierung zuerst diejenigen mit
vorerkrankungen zuerst medizinisches und
pflegerisches personal und insofern ist
sozusagen in der logik der sechs monate
jetzt vor allem eben auch diese gruppen
dran die wir zuerst geimpft haben mit
dem angebot eine auffrischimpfung das
macht ganz besonders viel sinn auch und
gerade für die älteren
mitbürger
radio der allgäusender sie haben heute
nochmal sehr anschaulich geschildert
bekommen wie schwierig die situation der
pflegekräfte ist haben sie alle davon
bestätigt frage was kann die politik
kurzfristig tun um diese pflegekräfte zu
unterstützen außer offensichtlich
geplanten einmalzahlungen und speziell
auch hier im dreiländereck sender immer
wieder fest dass pflegekräfte abgeworben
würden nach österreich in die schweiz
weil die bedingungen dort einfach besser
sind was kann die politik hier tun um
das möglichst zu verhindern bzw
die pflegekräfte die jetzt da sind zu
motivieren und zu halten unter seiner
sind ja die langfristigen fragen ihren
beutezügen auch diskutiert die jetzt
akku zwar nicht helfen aber ich würde
sie noch mal kurz an tatschen sozusagen
wir haben ja eine grundlegende
veränderung der krankenhausfinanzierung
gemacht dass nicht mehr zu lasten der
pflege am bett gespart werden kann das
war zu häufig in zu vielen kliniken der
fall dass wenn gespart wurde zuerst dort
das geht nicht mehr weil wir die pflege
sozusagen eins zu eins refinanzieren
rausgenommen haben aus der logik der
bisherigen krankenhausfinanzierung und
die krankenhäuser kriegen wenn sie 100
pflegekräfte zusätzlich einstellen auch
diese 100 zusätzlich bezahlt wenn sie
weniger haben auch weniger das
krankenhaus hat nichts davon wenn es
weniger pflegekräfte hat als dann auch
weniger geld hat so das ist eine
wichtige veränderung gewesen wir haben
personalbemessung eingeführt und es geht
am ende natürlich auch um bezahlung
damit übrigen auch geregelt dass
tarifsteigerung in der pflege eins zu
eins von den krankenkassen zu
refinanzieren sind wenn der
intensivpflege kraft die eine
fünfjährige ausbildung hat so lange wie
mancher studiert eine solche
intensivpflege kraft am ende 35 38.000
euro im jahr hat dann müssen wir als
gesellschaft tatsächlich die frage
stellen ist das auch angesichts der
ausbildung und der des bedarfes dem wir
haben ausreichend ich denke ziemlich
klar nicht und deswegen haben wir eben
geregelt wenn es dort tarifsteigerungen
gibt werden die auch von den
krankenkassen
entsprechend refinanziert ist aber der
langfristig ist jetzt wichtig da hat ja
frau kollegin grimm benne auch darauf
hingewiesen dass wir den krankenhäusern
jetzt vor allem auch es finanziell auch
möglich machen ihnen sicherheit geben
mögliche planbare operationen die nicht
dringend sind wir natürlich eine
dringliche geplante operation ansteht
dann soll sich auch wenn es eben geht
stattfinden können aber planbare
operationen verschoben werden können und
dass das krankenhaus das sich dann um
ein cockpit 19 patienten kümmert dann
auch entsprechend besser diese
behandlung bezahlt bekommt das ist
nämlich auch eine entlastung für die
pflege für die ärzte für das krankenhaus
insgesamt wenn ich an anderen stellen
zumindest da wo es planbar ist
runterfahren kann um mich auf 19
konzentriere dass ich da nicht den
finanziellen nachteile habe die regelung
hatten wir jetzt schon mal zwei mal
sogar oder genau genommen sogar dreimal
in den letzten 18 monaten und eine
solche regelung analog wollen wir auch
jetzt wieder einführen wie es vielleicht
nur mit einem satz ergänzen wir haben in
bayern ja schon ein programm auf den weg
gebracht wo wir zb pro bett auf der
normalstation pro tag 50 euro zahlen für
behandlung cobit und auf der
intensivstation 100 euro davon müssen 50
prozent mindestens 50 prozent für die
pflegekräfte zur verfügung gestellt
werden um auch da das signal zumindest
auch aus unserem land noch mal zu
stützen aber es ist natürlich wichtig
dass der bund insgesamt jetzt damit
reingeht ich will aber auch noch mal
deutlich machen wir müssen bei der
pflege mittel und langfristig auch
außerhalb des systems denken
bundesminister hat richtig angesprochen
dass pflege refinanziert wird und viele
andere dinge pflege darf kein
kostendruck werden wir müssen da schon
immer in alle richtungen denken auch das
thema leiharbeit dass wir heute
diskutiert haben dass zunehmend ein
ausweichen der pflegekraft in die
leiharbeit weil dort bessere
arbeitsbedingungen sind weil ich besser
meinem beruf mit der familie vereinbaren
kann das ist ja nicht der weg den wir
wollen ich glaube insgesamt die
ökonomisierung des systems ist ein
problem die zunehmende ökonomisierung
insgesamt und da müssen wir ran wenn sie
mich fragen dass eine der lehren aus der
pandemie
hat sich dank die letzten zwei fragen
kommen vom zdf
ich hätte gerne gewußt daß sie hatten
schon gesagt der winter wird hart liegt
auch jeder jetzt merkt jeder musste auch
bundesweit vielleicht schärfere
zweijährigen geben kommt da was
was sehr wichtig ist dass wir sozusagen
gemeinsamen rahmen gemeinsam mit
grundlagen im vorgehen haben aber die
entscheidung müssen natürlich auch
regional einfach nach der infektion lage
getroffen werden ist ja auch jemanden
meinetwegen stand heute in schleswig
holstein und das beispiel zu nehmen mit
einer deutlich geringeren incidents als
im schnitt schwer zu erklären warum die
gleichen maßnahmen dort gelten sollten
wir in einem landkreis mit einer
inzidenz von 600 die haben ja
mittlerweile auch und deswegen ist die
grundlage die maßstäbe dass die
einheitlich sind es wichtig und wir
haben im september eine vereinbarung
zwischen bund und länder auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wo wir eben
sagen drei geimpft genesen getestet
damit gehen wir durch herbst und winter
als basis maßnahme in allen bereichen
auch in allen ländern mit den schutz
konzepten mit den regeln und dem m und
jan damals schon diskutiert ob zwei
geimpft oder genesen nicht in regionen
mit hohen infektionszahlen und einer
belastung des gesundheitswesens auch
eine option dann sein sollte wir konnten
uns anfang september darauf nicht
verständigen dass das so ausdrücklich so
sein soll und ich finde es wichtig das
ist der erste bund länder beschluss
heute wo das gemeinsam drinsteht von
allen 16 ländern und im bund das 2g
geimpft und genesen in bestimmten lagen
hohe infektionszahlen hohe belastung
gesundheitswesens daneben auch regelhaft
eine option sein soll für die
zugangsbeschränkung zu bestimmten
veranstaltungen restaurants und anderes
mehr insofern ist das heute schon
wichtiger beschluss gewesen für ein
einheitliches verständnis dass zweig
notwendig werden kann und auch notwendig
ist unbedingt in regionen wo man eben
eine starke belastung hat und zum
abschluss die stuttgarter zeitung ja
meine redaktion hat mir noch eine frage
geschickt und zwar die rolle der stiko
es ist doch so dass ich die kümmern auch
sagten sie wollen ja gut dann für alle
aber die stücke sagt ab 70 bitte nur es
ist so dass viele ärzte sich darauf
berufen und sagen wir impfen erst ab 70
und trauben und sie sagten liegt unsere
kv gesagt wir kriegen das schon gestemmt
beantworten sagt die kv das auch
tatsache aber ist das noch nicht mal die
die hochbetagten zeitnah muss dann
können wir haben fälle in baden
württemberg wo
87-jährige laufen termin zum impfen im
dezember oder im nächsten jahr
vertröstet werden also vom bbi ist die
rolle der stiko wollen die da eine
änderung also zuerst einmal wenn ich
kurz darf habe ich gestern ja gemeinsam
klaus holetschek auch für die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz dabei mit
den ärzteverbänden
bundesärztekammer kassenärztlicher
bundesvereinigung
welche bund marburger boden öffentlicher
dienst ärzte öffentlicher
gesundheitsdienst betriebsärztin eine
gemeinsame
gemeinsames gespräch gehabt und wir
haben uns darauf verständigt dass die
sechs monate
sechs monate nach der zweite impfung der
richtige maßstab sind für das angebot
an diejenigen die eine auffrischimpfung
wünschen insbesondere aber eben wie auch
werben aktiv bei älteren bei menschen
mit vorerkrankungen bei medizinischen
pflegerischen personals
ich sage noch einmal diese sechs monats
regelung die eher sinn macht die sich
einfach herleitet weil man sieht nach
etwa sechs ist auch keinen stichtag
übrigens ausdrücklich zu sagen nach
sechs monaten und einem tag ist der
impfschutz nicht weg damit kein falscher
eindruck entsteht wir sehen nur das nach
etwa sechs monaten die wirkung
in unterschiedlichem ausmaße je nach
individueller situation aber in etwa
beginnt nachzulassen
und wenn wir dann schauen wir haben wir
vor sechs monaten oder mehr geimpft dann
ist das in sich schon die priorisierung
die wir jetzt eben auch brauchen ich
sage es noch einmal da ist überhaupt
kein gegensatz und wir sollten auch
aufhören ständig welche zu konstruieren
es sind logischerweise weil im januar
februar märz april zuerst die ältesten
die höchst betagten pflegebedürftigen
die menschen mit vorerkrankungen
medizinisches und pflegerisches personal
geimpft worden sind sind logischerweise
die ersten die jetzt sechs monate her
haben dass sie die zweitimpfung bekommen
haben genau diese personengruppe und
insofern sind da ziemlich einig zum
zweiten ist es so das hatten wir schon
bei den kinder und jugendlichen
impfungen das eine sind empfehlungen das
andere ist die frage wo ist es möglich
und vorsorglich in einer pandemie auch
sinnvoll und angezeigt wir haben eine
zulassung dieser impfstoffe ausdrücklich
durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde zu einer
auffrischimpfung wir haben eine impf
verordnung des bundes in dem ein
anspruch für alle geregelt ist eine
entsprechende auffrischimpfung bekommen
zu können und vor allem auch dass die
ärzte vergütet werden für die
entsprechende
auffrischimpfung und vor allem haben wir
eine vereinbarung gestern mit der
ärzteschaft und heute mit den ländern
dass wir eben genau diese impfungen
entsprechend auch anbieten am ende ist
es ja eine persönliche entscheidung des
einzelnen im zweifel im gespräch mit
seinem arzt ob er sich eine
auffrischimpfung
machten lässt geben lässt oder nicht
aber sie muss möglich sein denn sie
haben in einem recht das wird uns ja
auch geschildert dass es 83 85 67
jährige gibt die eine auffrischimpfung
sich wünschen die arbeiten teilen bisher
schwer hat einen zeitnahen termin zu
bekommen ich bin sehr dankbar für das
signal der ärzteschaft auch gestern dass
wir das gemeinsam jetzt ich weiß was ich
weiß was in den praxen los ist also die
sind ja auch grippe es ist insgesamt
eine zeit mit mehr atemwegserkrankungen
da ist viel los deswegen ist das jetzt
auch für alle noch mal ein kraftakt aber
ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir diesen
kraftakt noch einmal gemeinsam gemeinsam
auch machen und ich kann jetzt nur aus
meiner heimat im westmünsterland
berichten alle die da vor ort impfen an
mir beschrieben dass die letzten zwei
drei tage auch durch die öffentliche
debatte die nachfrage nach den
auffrischimpfungen deutlich und zwar
deutlich angestiegen ist das ist ja
genau das was wir jetzt brauchen wir das
vielleicht mit einem satz noch mal
unterstreichen weil ich gestern in dem
gespräch mit dabei sein konnte es war
klar dass wir jetzt eine einheitliche
und gemeinsame kommunikation in die
richtung auch machen wollen deswegen ist
der beschluss heute auch wichtig und
richtig das thema antikörpertest sv
angesprochen worden ist im gespräch mit
dem hausarzt kann das sicherlich auch
noch mal eine rolle spielen in der
beurteilung der jeweiligen situation das
gibt torhaus setzte sie sagen da kann
ich ableiten wenn das notwendig ist das
muss jeder selber entscheiden derart
spielte in diesem ganzen bereich eine
wichtige rolle aber wenn wir die daten
ansehen aus israel dann wissen wir dass
wir damit ein werkzeug haben das uns
jetzt helfen kann in dieser situation
die sich dramatisch verschärft hat auf
den intensivstationen und das ist die
botschaft die wir damit glaube ich auch
nach draußen geben herzlichen dank für
ihre fragen zu einem abschluss wort
dafür noch einmal an minister holetschek
geben ich habe kein großes
abschiedsworte oder abschluss wort
sondern die kolleginnen wird in zukunft
nächstes jahr den vorsitz übernehmen der
gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsministerkonferenz darf mich
da jetzt schon sehr herzlich bedanken
für die gute zusammenarbeit und wir
haben gedacht lieber herr landrat was
kann man besseres schenken aus der
region einen apfelbaum von bayern nach
sachsen anhalt möge blühen und gedeihen
wie unser gemeinsamer wille das beste
für die menschen in deutschland zu
erreichen vielen dank und alle probleme
musste sachsen anhalt